I just wanted to thank you again for
joining us today mr. bell
to take the discussion in a slightly
different direction in our class
discussions we've talked a lot about how
social entrepreneurs often choose to
invest in individuals more so than they
even invest in causes we've also talked
about out sometimes opportunities arise
that we instantly know we want to
support and like in New York Times
interview you said that you're driven
largely by a sense of rebellion even
anger sometimes and with the causes you
choose but you've also had the
opportunity to work with amazing
influential individuals who have
supported where do you think you find
the balance between supporting
individuals and causes I haven't
propensity for supporting individuals
who embrace my causes rather narrow draw
the self-serving but one of the miracles
of my journey that I look at all the
people that have really shaped history
every one of them but are in my life
experienced called me and invited me to
come into their space to become engaged
in what they did Eleanor Roosevelt to me
is the greatest woman ever in my time in
my lifetime what she was and what she
did and the way in which she did it but
in these invitations that were extended
I walked in and I was curious as to what
specifically did they want me to do and
most of the time what they asked before
was to use the power of my heart to
serve as some specific need Eleanor
Roosevelt had a lot of interest in
humanity and they and the welfare of
children the human rights manifesto that
she helped design and create letters to
the Declaration of the human rights of a
child it was her influence
that created these documents which
incidentally the human rights of the
child as the own America is the only
nation in the world that was never
signed that treaty every other nation
has come to the table inside America
refuses which says a lot about the decay
of our own sense of mission but in every
instance it was what was asked of me I
never had to impose anything and they
unlocked my sense of creativity what can
I best do to make this thing happen and
to service this cause which I have never
thought about before or never thought I
would engage so it was this reciprocity
they called i answered and they forced
me to examine in my my tool kit what
tools when I best used to apply to the
ends they wanted us to achieve and
always think that nourished that was
that I always trusted them I trusted
their vision I trusted their view I
trusted their humor I trusted their
humanity and if I could throw myself and
without any concern for consequence it
was even if we were to die one of the
great glories and death and all that
stuff was really the fact that the co
I'm dying with you know like if I got to
close my eyes and the last thing I see
is not the king or you you know then
what a way to go it's just everything
about it said to me out in the best
place I can be and everything that I did
service that fact I'm amazing at the age
of 85 in America with all of our value
systems I'm able to sit here at Yale
University and talked a bunch of young
people that I never ever saw before I
may never see again but that they're
interested in my opinion is to me I
can't put a value on that that's as
touching and is meaningful to me about
how my life has been spent then the fact
that this moment Carrie
value for you don't get no better than
this it really doesn't thank you thank
you Harry Belafonte for never in my
wildest wildest imaginings what I think
that you would share a few bars of deo
with us yeah and for the wisdom that you
brought to the class and thank you
students for joining in this most
inspiring conversation with what who I
believed to be one of the world's
greatest philanthropist this has been
philanthropy in action you know Harry
Belafonte shared with us that moment in
which the entire world was singing his
song Dayo and he thought how could I use
that moment to make the world a better
place and he did and he talks about how
we actually find our moral Center and
how we make that decision about whether
we are invested in making money or in
the moment that he said when he wakes up
and he can speak to Nelson Mandela and
we are so privileged here today that we
could wake up today to speak with Harry
Belafonte and there is no greater
privilege that I can imagine now what
are you going to do to change the world